good morning Boyle oh good morning
Cavanaugh after our disagreement
yesterday I went online to read your
culinary blogs and scoff to my dismay I
actually learned something about how
food tells a story so I made Kevin this
it's warm it's a croque monsieur Kevin
and I shared one on a rainy afternoon in
Paris on our first anniversary it's one
of our most treasured memories I'm sure
it's not up to your standards but Kevin
seemed to enjoy it so thank you for your
guidance gross huh no it's perfect
he's a natural ship now I know how
Salieri felt he Rosa the Flatbush diners
pie is terrible it's inedible food is
supposed to be edible so you were lying
what the hell Boyle crust isn't any
better
it's fancier but it's all bells and
whistles desserts don't need to be
clever they just need to be good this is
the best pie in New York City Apple from
Argos bakery founded 1910 recipe
unchanged taste it
is amazing this part is so good I heard
it you just graduated high school
[ __ ] sorry I said [ __ ] I'm just
really worked up do you know this pizza
is much better than last time
you've always ranked dead last in
structural integrity and sauce thank you
hey you sure it's a good idea to eat all
this Sh warmer right before your tux
fitting oh yeah I'm not gonna be one of
those grooms who doesn't eat Frenchy I
feel like a teenager
I feel like I'm 40 again chewing this
shiso leaf it'll give her kissing
[Music]
delicious so Vivien do you ever go watch
hockey no I'm not one for sports of
course you're not my graduate student
told me the craziest story about her
family hey can you pass me the maple
syrup please
speaking of where does the best maple
syrup come from again for not oh and
Canada Canada hey that reminds me
weren't the two of you talking about
maybe moving there oh yeah we are so
excited to start this new chapter of our
lives together
yeah well although I have to say as
someone who's read many of the older
chapters in Charles's life I wonder if
that's the best thing for him that's so
sweet of you to care but Chuck is
excited about moving to Canada right
baby mmm I feel very uncomfortable
saying this to you but it doesn't seem
like it's worth it
unless you think it is I do like I said
Salle's is an institution and it's the
best pizza in the neighborhood I'm sorry
Jake
sounds only the eighth best I put out a
weekly Brooklyn Pizza ranking email
blast Sal's has the fourth best texture
ninth-best crust 12th best cheese and
honestly they're only 7th and mouthfeel
mouthfeel what is that the inside of
your cheeks are very sensitive it's like
the inside of your thighs except with
the tongue Oh God
Mario this pie needs work good
consistency on the crust the cheese a
sauce ratio it's a travesty
do you have to spit in a word yes
amateurs go tasting they fill up and
they lose their palate by the third
slice I take just very seriously totally
what is going on out there
we can't tell cop stories Kevin doesn't
find me charming and a native English
speaker referred to captain Holt is
hilarious
I am flummoxed that's a word I learned
for this party and I am it well I'm
doing fine really
Raymond those slacks are a knockout do
you think you heard that well because
you yelled it shut up
from now on we play to our strengths
Charles you know everything about food
that's all you talk about
I mean I don't think anyone will ever
know everything about food it's an
evolving discipline that's great stuff
it's so boring don't waste it now the
first step in learning how to cook is
learning how to taste so close your eyes
and open your mouth
this isn't Burning Man Boyle tell me
what I'm eating fine it's a sharp
Vermont Cabot now describe what you
taste
cheese and cheese okay that's good
but try being more descriptive I know
you love peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches why their components have a
long shelf life they are cost-effective
they're they're so simple a child could
make them okay I was looking for more of
an emotional connection for example my
favorite meal is a simple roast chicken
and potatoes was the only dish my mother
knew how to cook and when I eat it I
feel as though I am once again inside
her womb what's your story behind a PB&J
I want a sandwich I make a sandwich I
eat a sandwich my last meal on earth
that's a great question I'd go classic
French Ortolan tiny songbird eaten a
single bite bones and all and open
defiance of God
it's illegal to consume Ortolan but I
actually got academic dispensation to
eat one once the beak very crunchy that
is literally the sexiest thing anyone
has ever said
how were you single you're not seeing
any way No
there's nobody in my life sort of a sad
thing to wink about and I realize now
Jake I gotta tell you the engaged life
is amazing especially sexually well I
don't want to pry it up right I want you
to know this no vivy and I have a
wonderful intercourse itinerary that we
have planned I'm usually more of a
chocolate guy but this one's closer so
I'm gonna oh ha ha
Bhaiji cake why that's habanero pepper
frosting because her marriage is going
to say Oh unless you think it's a bad
idea no sounds like a great idea Oprah
to one ah pepper relish on your arancini
very playful cut through the richness
add a little levity I love that you
really know your food you could say it's
the only thing I'm allowed to talk about
I'm Charles I work with captain Holt
I'm Vivian ludley I work with Kevin no V
Vivian ludley author of stone fruits and
stone stones foot of the Paleolithic era
I'm a huge fan
it's got the best recipes for making
salads out of moss the trick is you have
to lean into the dirt taste
we know you burned down Sal's Gino you
hated him because his pizza was better
than yours that's not true
Gino's pizzas always been the tastiest
wrong according to Boyle's email blast
it was downright lousy before we made it
so suspicious when he suddenly loved it
cross was char the cheese was stringy
and flavorless but the sauce Omata on
the sauce continued sorry six out of 12
out of 12 why for the 12 components of
food satisfaction salty sweet sour
bitter umami odor sound sound come on
try her nasty pie oh wow dr. puff pie I
ever had what's this we were running
calls to pawn shops and then waiting for
them to call back I didn't ask what you
were doing I asked what you are doing
I taste us it's over I won it's
unacceptable if you want to know which
restaurant has better pies you can't
just have one guy try one pie from each
place everybody needs to try all the
pies from both places we don't be here
while many people think that scrambled
eggs are the easiest food to make that
is incredibly foolish they are a highly
nuanced and complicated dish okay now go
ahead and pour your eggs right into the
pan nice and slow Oh okay now what do I
do
oh boy hey we hear that sizzle that
means the heat is a little too high on
those eggs well the higher the heat the
faster the eggs cook the sooner Kevin
eats am i incorrect no you make an
excellent point but we don't want to
feed Kevin burned garbage cooking it's
about patience are you completely insane
you never saltcan a pen to hand the hand
is the middle
and okay what you did is the culinary
equivalent of unprotected sex you know
what you sir are not ready to scramble
eggs hand over your spatula fine I only
wish in return I could get back all the
time I just wasted on this futile
project I'm just gonna make Kevin plain
toast for breakfast Oh
you